[Music]
foreign
okay
walter go ahead and um
can you hear me all right this is dr
walter korschetz i'm the director of the
neurological institute at nih
and it's a great pleasure to introduce
dr eve martyr
as a plenary speaker this afternoon at
the brain initiative
meeting and she's going to talk about
the principles of circuit functions from
the study of small circuits
eve has been a great friend of ninds
and the brain initiative from its very
beginning she is the
victor and gwendolyn binefield
university professor at brandeis
university
she's a past president of the society
for neuroscience
a member of the national academy of
sciences the national academy of
medicine
she's received many many awards
including the miriam saltpeter memorial
award for women in
neuroscience and the gerard prize
from the society for neuroscience
eve has really exemplified
the neuroscientists the modern
neuroscientists
she has demonstrated an incredible
passion
and love for neuroscience for many
decades
and she is extremely well known for her
tremendous mentoring
abilities and her
commitment to women in neuroscience
she's worked her whole life
on what she calls small circuits this is
not simple circuits as she will tell you
but
complicated small circuits and there
she's been able to dig very deeply
into how these circuits are hardwired
but also how they can be flexible
in response to the environment and her
work
includes you know very exquisite
recording
from these small circuits but
has has really uh changed the field
by uh bringing this data into
developing models for how these small
circuits work
and it's through this this merger of
electrophysiology
and computational neuroscience that
she's made a greatest
impact in the field so it's a tremendous
pleasure
uh to introduce dr martyr and and her
quality lecture today thank you very
much
i would like to thank you for the
introduction and
for the invitation to give this talk
today
um it is it's a great privilege to be
part of the
branch brain initiative investigators
meeting
and i feel a great deal of affinity for
this whole program since i was there in
the
in the very beginning what i want to
talk to you
about today are first some conclusions
um and insights have come from as you'll
see in a moment
50 years of working on small circuits
and then i'd like to bring you up to
date with what we're working on today
so but before starting i would like to
just pay homage to the wonderful people
with whom i've had the privilege to work
all these years
my present lab is up there on the left
and then i have
a whole variety of people who were in
the lab and who've moved on to
a variety of positions including faculty
positions
in academic appointments and
appointments in industry and government
and then i also want to honor my
large number of collaborators and
mentors
now what i'm going to do
is spend a short period of time giving
you
what i call lessons for 50 years of
spending small circuits
and i realized that i first started
working on small circuits in 1970 as a
second year graduate student so it
really is 50 years
so why study small circuits in
particular
in my case small motor circuits and what
lessons can we
learn so i still work on a small
set of a set of small motor circuits for
precisely the same reasons why i started
out with them 50 years ago
and that is sort of an interesting set
of conclusions
but why first neurons can be
unambiguously identified
and i think this is extremely important
as one approaches
trying to understand circuits circuit
outputs in motor circuits in particular
are easily and unambiguously measurable
and for me this is absolutely necessary
i don't understand how you can study a
circuit
if you can't know what its output is and
know when its output is normal or
abnormal
in small circuits the connectivity is
often
determinable um sometimes with
difficulty sometimes with ease
but certainly it's determinable many
circuit elements can be individually
manipulated it will and this is also
extremely important
and then for me personally it is also
possible
to determine the role of membrane
synaptic currents and cell and circuit
dynamics
so the rhythmic motor circuits
that we have studied include half center
oscillators that's reciprocal inhibition
between
two neurons and those circuits in a
sense become
the simplest circuit that many people
have studied and they've given us
a tremendous amount of insight in how
you go from
cellular properties and single neurons
and synapses to circuit dynamics
we've worked on the crustacean cardiac
ganglion this is nine neurons
with excitatory feed forward and
feedback
connections it produces
a rhythmic motor pattern that drives the
heart
that most of my on my scientific career
working on the pyloric rhythm of the
somatogastric
nervous system this is a triphasic
rhythm driven by a pacemaker
with embedded half-center oscillators
and you'll hear more about that in a
minute
and the gastric mill rhythm of the sdg
which is
a slow episodic rhythm that's turned on
and off in response to feeding
with a half center at the center of it
which is enabled by descending
modulatory inputs
now you might ask why study
different small circuits and i think
this goes to a point i'm going to come
to
come back to in a minute in a minute
which is
one of the challenges of working as an
experimentalist or for that matter as a
theorist
in any system is to understand when
you're seeing results that are
idiosyncratic
to your preparation or your problem and
when
you're seeing general principles and
everything i'm going to tell you about
today are a series of conclusions that
really
are general and they and we've seen
very similar data regardless of the
connectivity of the structure of the
circuit because we've done it in all
these different oil circuits
okay so what did we learn from studying
these small circuits
um all circuits that i know are
modulated by
many peptides and amines at all for
synaptic strength and intrinsic
excitability
i'm not going to talk about that today
but many of you know
a lot of the work that we and others
have done on
small motor circuits in the role of
modulators
similar motor patterns can be produced
by variable sets of cellular and circuit
parameters across
animals and i will come back to this
a little later and then this next
principle is one that i'm really excited
about now
and i'll call it neurons and circuits
can smoothly slide through multiple
mechanisms to extend the resilience and
dynamic range
and this is one of the really exciting
problems that we're setting today
and then individuals in individual
animals individual people
show differential resilience to extreme
perturbations
and you'll see in a moment that we think
that's because of their
underlying um properties
so but i'd like to make one more point
before leaving these sort of general
introductory comments
and that is to say in my mind
theoretical and computational work
is the best way we have to know which
experimental results are general
and which are idiosyncratic to that
preparation because experimental data
always show you only
part of the potential answer i first
learned this in 1990
with a paper that we published with tom
kepler
and larry abbott where in a very very
simple model
tom showed us that the answer that scott
hooper had gotten
in a very beautiful set of experimental
studies was only half of the possible
answers
and i didn't know the other case was
there
until we saw it in the theory and i
think it's very very important
to remember that in theory
you can see all possible cases or all
possible answers
whereas if you study a preparation you
may only see part of the truth
or part of the possibles now the problem
that we've been studying most recently
is a set of questions that i
call how tightly tuned to the parameters
that govern synaptic space
and intrinsic properties need to be for
good enough circuit behavior
or how different can the underlying
structures of normal healthy brains
be one to another and then how is
individual variability related to
resilience to challenge when we started
talking about this
probably now 10 or 15 years ago it was
very
unconventional i think nowadays
as our ability to do genetic work has
become more and more and more powerful i
think this is much more
a mainstream problem than it was when we
started doing this
so the small circuits we're going to
talk to you about
here is an introductory slide to
the magagastric nervous system
and the pyloric rhythm which is one of
the two major rhythms produced by the
somatic asterisk nervous system
the stomatogastric ganglion which is
seen um
or this many gastric nervous system is
seen in the
round petri dish that's pinned down
there are three colored microelectrodes
inserted into the stomata of the stg
the stg has um what's metagastrogamine
has 26 to 30 somata depending on the
species
and they're quite large they're about
100 microns diameter so it's very easy
to put multiple intracellular recordings
um into the ganglion now there are
three anterior ganglia called
conditional esophageal ganglia
that send descending modulatory inputs
into the nerve pill of this magostro
ganglion
and exiting the stomatogastric ganglion
there are motor nerves that go out to 40
pairs of striat muscles that move
the lobster of the crab stomach and we
record
extracellularly from those motor nerves
and
intracellularly as you see from the
stomata now
it's very very important that you
understand that the
neurons are are identified unambiguously
on the basis of their the projection
patterns
um that is to say which muscles
each neuron goes on to innervate so it's
the extracellular recordings from the
motor nerves
that allow us to unambiguously identify
the neurons when we penetrate them with
microelectrodes
in the middle panel you see simultaneous
intracellular
recordings from the lp py and pv neurons
these are three neurons of the pyloric
rhythm
and you can see this beautiful triphasic
rhythm that
persists in the animal at all times in
the animal it's on
just like your respiratory rhythm is on
and what we see
is um that under different behavioral
circumstances
the frequency and the phase
relationships of the rhythm are variable
just as is your respiratory rhythm but
it's always there and so those three
simultaneous intracellular recordings
allow you to see
depolarizations of the membrane
potential burst of action potentials
followed by
silent phases um and the the bottom of
those four traces is an extracellular
recording
from the motor neuron that's carrying
each of those three units
and they're color coded so you can see
which is which
now on the right you see what we used to
call
1980 we called this a connectivity
diagram or a wiring diagram
and it was the goal of the early workers
on rhythmic motor systems to come up
with an unambiguous or
a wiring diagram because the early
workers the people who were studying and
what they used to call simple systems
and now we know they're not simple
they're just small
their their their goal was to really say
okay one of the cells
how are they connected and then they
they had this belief that that would
automatically give them deep insight
into how
it would work or how it worked um in
1980
we had the wiring diagram that you'll
see over there
and if i had shown you this connectivity
diagram or wiring diagram and not
showing you the dynamics of the
recordings in the middle panel
there's absolutely no way that you'd be
able to predict those dynamics from this
connectivity diagram
and that's because what's missing in
that connectivity diagram
are the strengths and time courses of
the synaptic interactions
and all of the voltage and time
dependent currents each of the neurons
now i should just walk you through that
wiring diagram a little bit
the resistor symbol that you'll see
there is
denotes an electrical junction a gap
junction between those neurons
the ab neuron is an interneuron see
one of only two or three empty neurons
in the magnetic nervous system
and it's an intrinsic oscillator and
it's very tightly coupled to the pv
neurons and the pd neurons therefore
fire in bursts
and you can see them in the blue traces
on the
in the middle panel all of those filled
circles are chemical
inhibitory synapses and so you can see
here this whole circuit runs on
electrical synapses and chemical
inhibition and these neurons fire on
rebound from inhibition and so rebound
from inhibition
is a very important timing cue
in the somatogastric nervous system and
you can see there are many instances
of reciprocal inhibition for example pd
and lp
are reciprocally inhibitory as our lp
and py
and these are examples of embedded half
center oscillators
where that little circuit motif is
repeated over and over again
so in 1980 we had this wiring diagram
and we had a word model of how the
circuit generated its triphasic rhythm
we have a pacemaker kernel consisting of
the one a b neuron of the two pd neurons
which rhythmically inhibit the lp and
the py neurons
those those neurons fire and rebound
from the inhibition
and the lp fires earlier on rebound
because
of the strength of the synaptic
interactions and the kinds of membrane
currents it has
when lp fires it shuts off py eventually
py recovers from its inhibition it shuts
off the lp
and then the oscillator starts again so
that is a word model
it's still approximately true but if you
one really wanted to have a satisfactory
understanding
of why the dynamics are the way they
really are you would need to go
much further now
and i would just like to say that for
those of you who are really interested
in
interconnectomics i always like to say
and i've always said
that the the wiring diagram or the
connectivity
diagram or the connectome is absolutely
essential
and completely insufficient for
understanding how a circuit works
you can't understand how a circuit works
without
a connectome and the connectome is just
the beginning
okay now here are the motor patterns
for the full somatogastric ganglion and
now
and up on the top trace you can see lp
pypv that's the fast pyloric rhythm
and this slide introduces you to the
second rhythm the slower gastric mill
rhythm
and you can see that in the
intracellular recording on the bottom of
lg
which is now firing in bursts which are
about 10 times slower
than the fast pyloric rhythm that you
see on
on the lvm now i just want to call your
attention
to two neurons that are labeled ic and
vb
on that nerve that's called the mvn and
they are firing
in time with the fast pylor rhythm and
they're firing in an
envelope in time with a slower gastric
milgram
so these two neurons in a sense are
taking part in two different rhythms a
fast rhythm and a slow rhythm
and the extent to which they participate
in the generation of both of those
rhythms
is really a fascinating problem now
the next slide shows you the
connectome or the connectivity diagram
for the full metagastric nervous system
and in red you can see highlighted the
pdlp half center oscillator that i
pointed to you before
in blue you can see there's a second
half center oscillator
between the lg neuron interneuron one
and in the black neuron that's filled in
is ic that's one of those neurons
that participates in both rhythms and is
in a sense multiplexing both rhythms
now i'd like to show you two more things
about this connectivity diagram
first of all there are tons of
electrical synapses
and electrical synapses and this is a
big principle
electrical synapses create parallel
pathways
that is to say multiple routes by which
information can travel
between neurons now what you see
here and this is an insight that
gabrielle gooder asked you at the time
was a graduate student in my lab and
she's gone on to bigger and better
things since
but she noticed something extremely
interesting
she has the spirit of a theorist
and she noticed at the center of this
diagram there's a five
cell symmetrical circuit so if you look
you can see
the half center oscillator of lg and
engineering one
and interneuron one also inhibits
ic and then there's a half center
oscillator
between pd and lp and pv
also inhibits ic and now you also can
see that there's an electrical junction
the backbone
of lpic and lg are all connected but
what gabrielle noticed
and this goes back to the concept of
parallel pathways
that interneuron 1 could
influence ic's behavior both
monosynaptically
and via a polysynaptic pathway
internal one to lg and then across the
electrical
coupling likewise pv monosynaptically
can inhibit ic and also influence it
through
the lp and that electrical junction so
what gabrielle wanted to do
is she wanted to build a computational
model to help her understand
in the way she framed it um
what the what the war
she as she called it then the war
between the fast oscillator the pb and
lp
and the slow oscillator lg and
interneuron one
how they would play um
how how they would contribute to the
dynamics of what the ic was doing
so she set out to build a model to study
that five
cell symmetrical circuit and she used
what are called morris lakar model
neurons these are
individual oscillator models with
calcium currents and uh potassium
current and elite current
and she set out with each of the
five neurons and she now named them f1
f2 for fast one pass two so she started
out with parameters of the oscillator so
that when isolated
they would fire quickly she called the
next neuron a hub neuron
h n and she set it out set up parameters
of the model
so that it would be a moderate
an oscillator with a moderate frequency
and then she
named s1 and s2 to mean slow ones slow
two neurons
and she set up parameters so that they
would
fire more slowly when um
when in isolation and then on the right
you see
when f1 and f2 are reciprocally
inhibitory
they're firing out of phase as you guys
expect likewise on the bottom left when
s1 and s2
are reciprocally inhibitory they're
following out of phase
and if you now turn off all the chemical
synapses and just look at the electrical
synapses
between f2 hn and s2 obviously you can
see there
they're coming into synchrony as you'd
expect so what happens
now when you try and put everything
together
here so now
we're putting the whole model together
and i have two more things i have to
tell you
and that is that gabrielle came up with
a really beautiful way
of showing you what the frequency of all
the elements in the circuit are
so on the top right you see four
concentric circles
and a square and the outer two circles
are the frequency of f1 and f2 the
square
is the frequency of the hn neuron and
the two inner circles of the frequency
of
the two slow neurons and
what this allows you to see in a very
quick glimpse
what's going on with all of the cells in
the circuit
um and this is on a heat map where fast
is red and
slow is blood um and then
we can see that she labeled the
strengths of those synapses
so that jinxing a the conductance of
synapse a
is the the monosynaptic connection from
f1 to hn or from
s1 to hn the electrical synapse
conductance is gl
gel and then the conductance of the
reciprocal inhibitory synapses or gcnv
so now on the in the set of recordings
on the
bottom left you can see one set of
parameters
give you the two f1 and f2 are firing an
alternation quickly
hn is firing in time with the slow
rhythm
which is seen in the bottom two traces
and you can see in the little cartoon
um that you have two orange and three
blue
neurons and that's giving you a
visualization
of what those cells are doing like what
but on the right you see when gabrielle
changed the parameters
all five cells are now found at the same
frequency
and therefore all five are shown in
green
so this now gives us a tool to look at
a parameter search and
this is what gabrielle calls a parameter
scape
on the on the x-axis you can see
the gsin a that is to say the values of
the
the synaptic conductance and on the
on the y axis you have the electrical
synapse conductance and now you can see
using gabrielle's visualization tool
you can see whole regions in the
parameter escape with
with characteristic and interesting
behaviors
so in the in the large part on the upper
right which is called d
you can see only one of the
only only the f1 is firing quickly and
all four other cells are firing slowly
the section labeled g the green one
they're all going at the same frequency
to the
to the left in in h you can see
and this abuts on d you can see an area
where only one neuron is firing slowly
and all
the other four are firing relatively
quickly and this allows you to
visualize um at what happens
across a whole range of parameters
to the the patterns and the the
frequencies of all the
five cells in the neuron okay so
the next slide allows me to show you
or make a point that i think you
probably all know but this is just a
really nice way of
visualizing it if you were to start out
with a network in region h
and apply a modulator a which increases
gcna as many modulators can do that
alter synaptic strength
if you start out in h it can take you
across
two regions and can qualitatively
completely alter the dynamics of the
circuit
and i think it's pretty easy to see that
however if you
start a little over
um and now you start out on the
left hand part of
[Music]
region d now you can alter the strength
of gcn a
five or six fold more than we saw in the
previous example
but see no change in qualitative
behavior and so this is an example of
state dependent modulation depending on
where you're starting
you can a small amount of modulator can
either give you a
large or small quality of change in
behavior
and an effective modulator which is much
larger in principle may have a much
smaller effect on circuit dynamics
now i would just like to
show you a few more insights from this
work
before leaving it
in the the last figure of this paper
what gabrielle did is she
did three different manipulations to the
circuit
and they're shown the control value is
shown in
a all the way on the left and she's
starting out with
f1 and f2 firing slowly again
is firing i mean firing quickly hn is
firing slowly with s2 and s1
and then she decreased gcna and she
flipped
hn from firing slowly to firing quickly
and she went back to control and now in
the another set of simulations
she decreased the electrical synapse the
strength of the electrical synapse
and she was again able to flip
hn from flying slowly to firing quickly
and then in a third manipulation
she changed gcnv and again she was able
to
flip hn from firing slowly and firing
quickly
so these are three entirely different
circuit mechanisms that can produce
virtually the same change in behavior
and i think this is really important
because this shows you that even in a
circuit as simple
as a five cell circuit you can have
three
entirely different you know cellular
mechanisms
that produce virtually indistinguishable
changes in behavior
and i usually make a joke about this i'm
talking with a lot of graduates in the
room saying
that if you were graduating in berkeley
and you did the experiment in
b you'd send your paper off to nature
and they would publish it and say oh wow
you know
you had a mechanism for a change of
behavior and then there'd be a
graduate student sitting in um in berlin
who'd say
oh no that that lab is wrong i know the
answer
and they would um have done the
experiment shown and see
and maybe their paper would end up in
nature neuroscience
and then some poor graduate student in
some other place in hawaii would do the
experiment
in d and not be able to publish it
because the other two had already been
published
but basically all three answers are real
all and all three answers are right
but the deep lesson is that you have
a whole variety of ways of influencing
circuit output
and this is only in a circuit of five
neurons
and this is a rising precisely because
of those parallel pathways
and in this case those parallel pathways
are enabled by those electrical synapses
whenever you have parallel pathways you
have the possibility of having
multiple ways of producing very similar
circuit dynamics
now i'm going to skip the next slide
and now i'm going to go and
talk a little bit about work that astrid
prince um
first chris did that set us on the
a path um to what we're currently doing
now
and many of you have probably seen this
work um
astrid when she was in postdoc many many
years ago wanted to build a model of the
pyloric
rhythm and she was working she wanted to
build a
semi-realistic model with
conductance-based neurons and she
so she started adapting some model
neurons that had been in the lab
and she wanted to get some neurons that
behave like the ab pv
cell pacemaker group and neurons that
behave like lp
and the ones that behave like py and she
was having a tremendous amount of
trouble
finding neurons with the appropriate
behavior so
she decided she took um
these these models these model neurons
had
seven different conductances and she
chose six values to each those seven
conductances
and she simulated all against all and
she
created a database of 1.7 million model
neurons
and then she selected neurons with
behaviors that she wanted
to be good abpd cells or good lp cells
with py cells
and then she chose five or six of those
neurons
and five or six values for each of the
synaptic conductances in the network she
simulated
all against all again and she
ended up simulating um the output of
20 million model networks and then she
was able to select
from those that were good
pyloric models so this was all of her
neurons all of her networks 19
of them were what astrid called pyloric
like they would triphasic in the right
order
and 2.4 percent of them
she called good pyloric models because
they um had behaviors that fit within
the range of what dick luker had
measured
from a population of 99 um schematic out
of pyloric rhythms from homores
americanus
so the really important thing here and
this was
i think a real paradigm shift is astrid
was looking
not for one model that would capture the
mean behavior
of those 99 animals or 120 animals
or a thousand animals she was looking
for a
group of models that would capture the
range of what we saw
biologically and so she looked at
models and she came up with a whole
group of models
and that group of models now all had
behaviors that would have been
physiologically
within the population but the real
difference is
she was looking for a family of
solutions
rather than a single solution now what
can we learn from that
and this again is from that very very
well-known paper
um model network one model network two
you can see they're doing very similar
things
however when you look at the parameters
in those models
you can see that the underlying
parameters are entirely different
so for example um this
um the h conductance and the py that's
the
this what color is that um
the chartreuse um
h current was very large in model
network one and very small model network
two
the pylp synapse the
the purple one and model network one is
small it's big in
model network two the
the red the reds the red current which
is the eight current
and the abpd cell was big in model
network one
it's small in the model network too so
you can see that these two sets of
parameters
are totally different and yet
nonetheless
each of them is consistent with
producing variables in one behavior so
when i first started talking about this
it became pretty clear to me that this
was a really important result
because it said that you if taking at
face value
you would expect there to be
considerable variability
in any single parameter or group of
parameters that you measured in
biological systems
if this were this were right now when i
first started talking about this
to theorists what they said
that's all very well and good but
um you might you have to
believe that when you start perturbing
model network one and model network two
they're gonna be behave differently in
response to perturbations
precisely because the uh
the underlying parameters are different
and so
we realized that that was true that in
the universe of all possible
perturbations there had to be
perturbations
that would separate model network one
from model network two or all other
similar ones
but then the question is for the
universe of perturbations
that people or my the crabs that live
out in the ocean
are to see to what extent will the
natural perturbations that they see
separate or not the individual animals
so
this model brought up
these questions how variable the premium
is in real biological networks
do perturbations reveal cryptic animal
animal differences
and how reliably can animals with
intrinsic variability respond to
perturbations
so we set out to do a bunch of
experiments
and the first i'm only going to show you
one slide
um john mccain and david schultz um
recorded here you see intracellular
recordings from the lp neuron there's
one alpena in each animal
in two different animals um in the
network you can see they have very
similar dynamics
when john mark went into a voltage clamp
he was able to
show that the calcium activated
potassium current in
the blue lp was much larger than it was
in the green etc
and the conductance densities for
three different potassium currents were
seen in the left bottom
the mrna copy number taken from
single neurons those same single neurons
was also different across animals
and both the conductance densities
and the copy numbers show about a two to
six fold
variation across animals in the same
identified neuron
as we look now since then
my lab and dave schultz's lab have done
the same experiment for many many ion
channels
in many many different cell types and
you see this
repeating itself over and over again
there is about
a two to six fold this happens to be
mrna expression
in single identified neurons that have
been hand dissected
and you have this range of behaviors
across that population
nonetheless and the next slide
are some recordings that aging the
topology may just
slide like this shows that when you look
across animals even though when you look
at individual
parameters the behavior of the network
is very very similar
you can see that in these extracellular
motor patterns which show
lppypd and you see the same thing in
intracellular waveforms
animal one animal two animal three are
very very similar waveforms
so this is telling you that
individual synaptic and intrinsic
parameters can vary through six fold
across animals
even when they have very similar
behavior and this now becomes very very
interesting
to look at what happens in response to
perturbations and so over the last
number of years we've looked at a number
of perturbations
temperature which is a global
perturbation that influences all
biological processes
but does so differentially so that the
relationships among processes will be
altered
we've studied the effects of ph because
again
as the ocean changes and again it's a
global perturbation
and high potassium and i'm not going to
show you any of the data with
ph and high potassium but i am going to
show you a little bit about what happens
to temperature
so we biologists often
measure something we call the q10 which
expresses the temperature dependence of
the process
a q 10 of 1 is temperature invariant to
q10 of 2.
meaning that q10 is a loose way of
saying
q10 of 2 means that the process would
double
its rate is a function 10 degrees
centigrade and because it is an
exponential
q 10 of 3 um obviously things are
are growing now ion channel rate
constants can
have commonly will have cutanes of 2 to
4
but you can have very very temperature
sensitive channels with q10s of 11 or 50
or 100
so this now becomes a really interesting
problem
for the dynamics of circuits so now and
maybe i'll uh just briefly show you this
one slide this was a simulation that tim
o'leary
um built just to make this point
um and basically to give you a
an understanding what's going on if you
have a cell with a behavior
that's set up to have a characteristic
waveform at a given temperature
if each channel depends on temperature
differently
then you might imagine the things we get
out of whack
and not be able to maintain a constant
function
as the temperatures change and that's
what's happening here
in this model at in the green in the
middle you have
the three different models that were set
up
um at 10 and they were the same sets of
conductances
but the top one had one set of q10s the
second had a different set of q10s and
the third was a different set of q10s
and you can see in all three cases
even though the model started out with
the same behavior they were temperature
dependent different ways
and the set one
crashed or became inactive
in a depolarized area whereas q10
said three actually crashed in a
hyperpolarized regime
so this just tells you that this is a
non-trivial problem and it actually is a
very non-trivial
problem but what about biology well
biology has solved the problem because
that's why
biologists um and so
and these are experiments that
lamontagne who was a graduate student in
the lab did a number of years ago
and so here he took a crab
and he measured the pyloric rhythm and
these extra recordings
at 7 degrees and then at 19 degrees and
you can see
that the frequency of the rhythm is sped
up and that's
shown in the plot and you can see
that's the semi-long plot but the
phenomenal
finding here is that although the
frequency
sped up as you would expect as
temperature increase
the phase relationships that is the
normalized time at which the cells were
active relative to each other
was completely temperature and variant
and this was a stunning result
and i was really surprised when vermont
first showed that to me
so this is saying that if a crab out in
the water
um sees fluctuations from
over a pretty wide range of of
temperatures it will still be able to
maintain
its characteristic um function
and this is the same thing with
intracellular recordings at 7 11 15
19 23 degrees you can see the frequency
is increasing
but when lamont used the computer to
scale out
time he was able to overlay the 7 11 and
and 19 degree um traces and you can see
they superimposed upon each other
so that the changes in the behavior of
all the
q10s were such so the waveforms were
maintained
okay now however
so you have this set of permissive
temperatures
and these premises temperatures with a
crab in the north atlantic
are the temperatures that the animal
would usually see
but now when you start giving much more
extreme temperatures
as when you go higher in temperature
then lamont saw what he called um
crashes
when the network becomes um
discombobulated or disrupted
and here are four examples of four
different kinds of disruptions
and you can see each of these
disruptions was produced in a different
animal
and vermont and
the rest of us understood that as saying
that
if each animal had a different set of
underlying parameters you'd expect them
to crash differentially
and then very high temperatures can
produce
much more complete crashes there are 23
degrees
normal at 31 degrees you can see
complete loss of activity and 23
again recovery so temperature crashes
are widely variable within the
population
likely because the animal the animal
variability underlying circuits
structures and the conclusions from
these crashes
are at low temperatures all networks are
well behaved showing consistent changes
in frequency and outstanding temperature
compensation
each individual animal crashes with
individual dynamics
as predicted by their underlying
parameter differences but some
neuromodulators i didn't show you these
data these are
beautiful data that sarah haddad
collected but some neuromodulators can
expand the stable range to temperatures
while others make
preparations more temperature sensitive
i have a few more minutes i hope
and i would like to just show you a few
a few experiments that leandro alonso
has done looking at the effects of
temperature and computational models
because
there are a couple of more insights that
come from this first of all
it's if you randomly sample parameter
space
finding neurons and networks that are
temperature compensated shows they're
not common in the population
now evolution over many years has
allowed
the animals to find the sets of
solutions
that do work but now how do we find them
and we can in the questions we can talk
about how biological systems they find
them
but how do we find them computationally
so leandro
has worked with a series of genetic
algorithms
that he has used to find
temperature compensated models
and what i'm going to do before i
show you that i'm going to show you a
novel way of visualizing
what's going on with the membrane
currents that leandra came up with
so on the top trace you see an
intracellular model
we introduced intracellular recording of
a pacemaker model in black and now
i'm just showing you the inward and
outward currents
evolving over time so
the the outward currents are shown up
from the midline the inward current is
shown down as you would do in voltage
clamp
and on the highly compressed log scale
in black you're seeing the total
the total outward current and the very
bottom the total in returns
and then in the others you're seeing the
proportion of that total inward or
outward current
carried by each of the currents so in
purple you're seeing
the the eight current that's the
transient outward current potassium
current
in red you're seeing the sodium current
the inward current etc so this allows
you to see what's going on
over time so now let's look at
six different models um with
very very similar behavior and this is
one of my favorite slides
you have model a model b model c model d
model e model f visualize this way
and you can see their
electrophysiological behavior their
intrinsic properties
are virtually identical but nonetheless
if you just
look at the purple which is the a
current you can see the a current is
virtually
invisible in model a and is
really dominant and very important in
model f
even though model e has actually a
larger a current and the
conductance densities are shown on the
top the
it has a larger um number of
it has a larger maximal conductance but
the actual current
in the in model f is larger and now if
you look at the calcium potassium
current which is shown in orange
you can see it's very important in model
a
and then somewhat less important some of
the other models
so this is telling you that six neurons
which
to your eye look like they have almost
identical behavior
have entirely different underlying
mechanisms that are giving rise to that
behavior
and if you think forward you'll
immediately say oh that might mean
they'll behave
differently to perturbations and or to
pharmacological agents and so we'll
continue with that theme
so leonjo found some temperature
compensated
networks and now i just want to show you
what is
probably today my favorite slide he
looked at
a model at
10 degrees 15 it's at 20 degrees
we're looking at the pacemaker the
burster and now we're going to show you
the currents
flowing at the end of the last spike in
the burst
and here's the model at 10 degrees 11 12
13
whatever up to 25 degrees and you can
see
that at 10 you have a really large ache
a large a
current that's the purple and a really
small calcium activated k
whereas at 25 degrees the purple has
gotten much smaller
and the the calcium activated potassium
current has gotten much bigger
so i love this slide because it shows
you that the neuron
is able to smoothly slide between
mechanisms to maintain
an appropriate physiological behavior
without going through dead periods it's
basically
sliding through mechanism
very very smoothly to maintain function
now i probably don't have
i'm going to show you two more slides
and to show you now
two neurons model a and model b
at 10 degrees on the left and and 25
degrees
next to it and notice in model a
and i'm just plotting on the in blue you
have the behavior of the cell and then
below it
the values of the currents so the sodium
current
is the is the one the second one and you
can see it gets bigger as in model a
we can go from 10 degrees to 25
whereas in in the other model the model
b the sodium current gets smaller as you
go from 10 to 25.
likewise one of the calcium currents
gets much bigger
as you go from 10 to 25 and the other
one gets smaller
so this tells you the two models that
start out with very similar behavior
and nonetheless individual currents
can change their relative
role in the generation of that behavior
in response to temperature
now i'm going to skip
x and just end with one last with one
last slide
now up in a
you're seeing a network pdlppy
and at first you're seeing it with
the a current that's the transient
outward current at 100
at 10 degrees and when you turn off
that current the transient outward
potassium current
at 10 degrees you can see the network
becomes disrupted
however when you do the same
manipulation at 25 degrees
you can see the network maintains its
function perfectly well
it's almost perfectly well in contrast
if you look in orange and now we're
manipulating the calcium activated
potassium current
at 10 degrees the network is fine with a
hundred percent of the current
active but at
and that's maintained when you turn off
that current entirely
however if you look um
[Music]
at 25 degrees
and now you turn off that current the
network performance is entirely
disrupted
so this is a case in point where a
pharmacological manipulation
or genetic deletion will be
either more or less important
at one temperature than at the other
temperature in one case
the network is more resistant at high
temperature
in the other case it is much more
resistant
at low temperatures and i just like to
summarize
and say that individuals with similar
starting circuit performance
with relatively similar circuit
mechanisms in the control state
and nominals show entirely different
crash mechanisms
and i didn't actually show you that
completely but this is a cautionary tale
for thinking about disease you can have
five human beings who are all absolutely
fine until something awful happens
and they may crash whether it's
pharmacologically or some other um
because of totally different mechanisms
and i think as we start thinking about
diseases therapeutics this is really
important
and then my final
point is that multiple good enough
solutions to circuit performance in the
population
are necessary to ensure a substrate for
evolution
under diverse environmental conditions
and i'll stop there
walter i can't hear you
unmute yourself if you muted yourself
eve to walter i can't hear you
walter you've turned the green
microphone
next to your name if you turn that off
there are two questions that came in
during my talk
and i thought i would answer them first
the easy
first the easy one and then the less
easy one
the first question was are some of the
mechanisms seen in small circuits
conserved in the human brain
and my answer is absolutely
um i i've used small circuits
as a way of seeing principles which then
can easily
be looked for
as sort of guiding posts for studies
in large brains including the human
brain in my experience nothing we've
ever seen
in small nervous systems has failed to
show up
in larger brains once one knew what one
was looking for
the second question that came
in during the talk was
how do you anticipate that the
techniques from your research can be
scaled up
to study
the larger more difficult to access
systems
given the non-linearity and recurrence
of nervous systems
how do we find modular circuits that
behave relatively independently so we
can put them back together
and still interpret the sum of the parts
well that's the hard question
if i knew how to do that in large brains
i might be doing that and part of the
reason why
i continue to work on small brains
is precisely because
um i don't fully know how to do that
in large brains um i think there are
many of the new tools that
that the uh the brain
the brain initiative has um has
developed
many of the the new tools that the brain
initiative
has developed are really going to help
us
do exactly what this questioner is
asking for
now i'm seeing
a comment
um
okay so would somebody
okay would somebody put a a note in the
chat box that checkbox saying they can
hear me
because you can hear me now i can hear
you all day
all right all right sorry about that
okay so yeah
they're they're hearing you fine yes
right so
are you going to ask these questions or
should i just keep yeah let me ask let
me ask a question
um in terms of the multiple parameters
that
that could be seen in a cell based on
the models
to give an identical behavior
how do you think about how the cell
actually
sets those parameters what's the
feedback to the cell
so there's a whole other 15-minute
lecture
that i didn't give which is
which is about um homeostatic models and
a way of understanding the homeostasis
by which
the individual parameters of the cell
are controlled
and so in these models we imagine
um and there's a great deal of
experimental work as well
that every cell monitors its own
activity patterns and then
uses those activity patterns to control
the expression of its channel genes and
its synaptic inputs
to maintain a designated target activity
level
and so every cell might wanna
of a certain type may want to have a
certain characteristic activity pattern
we might find a different solution um to
producing that and so i think that's a
really important question and it's just
one that i didn't
talk about okay there was another
question
in terms of the parameter scope escape
the question is when you start to
perturb
the circuit do you actually do you
actually see
jumps in behavior or these or does it
look like a continuous function and so
the point is are there
bi-stable states of the circuit
or the multi-stable states in the
circuit
or is it kind of looks like a continuous
function as you
change parameters well you know the
answer in biology is always
all of the above because that's the way
biology works
but actually it depends what kinds of
perturbations you do
in the experimental systems we've
perturbed
um circuits with temperature with ph
with high potassium and
usually when you're within the operating
range
you see smooth and continuous changes
and transitions in behavior
almost all of the time and then you get
to
some sort of critical point when you
start seeing
disruptions and behaviors and that's
what i was talking about as crashes
um and then you get all sorts of
interesting
um behaviors some of which could be
um multi stabilities and by stabilities
and behavior
um on the way towards inactivity
does that make sense yep that makes
sense um
and then maybe if you could also talk a
little bit about
you know right from the beginning you
said that you know you wanted to study a
circuit where you can really identify
the cell types
and how they're connected and so
the hot uh projects in
neura in the brain initiative now are
trying to
determine cell types in very complex
circuits based on transcriptomics so
have you tried to look at how
transcriptomics
cell identification um
placed out in a circuit such as yours
where you really know
you have ground truth as to what the
different cells
are so in collaboration with dave
schultz who is
at the university of missouri we've done
some pretty extensive
pcr and rna-seq studies on
channel and receptor gene expression and
unambiguously identified somatogastric
ganglion cells and cardiac ganglion
cells
and what we see is that the
transcriptomic
data alone is insufficient to
unambiguously cluster or to correctly
cluster cells
and i would actually argue that
the that in order to really identify
cells you need some piece of anatomical
or projection pattern data along with
either electrophysiology and
transcriptomics
electrophysiology changes too easily
i think the transcriptomic data probably
is insufficient for all the reasons i
was talking about before
our cell identifications are based on
how the neurons project to
identified muscles and i suspect
that once you have projection data and
transcriptomics you'll have pretty good
financing with cell type identification
okay there's another question i don't
know if you've got into this
at all but the question is whether the
single cell changes developmentally over
time in a small circuit and
have you looked at this and can you
model how how the
behavior changes in in development in
the crab
okay so for a number of years
pia meron first started doing
development of the
cells in the lobster stomatogastric
nervous system
and then for a number of years we worked
on development of the
pyloric motor patterns and gastric motor
patterns
in the lobster stomatogastric ganglion
so the story is that
fifty percent of the way through
embryonic development
the ganglion's active um
the the separation between the pyloric
and the gastric mill networks
is is not fully there um the
preparations are far less regular and
then
over time modulators come in and
everything settles down
so that by the time the animals go
through their first larval stage
they're generating pretty decent um
rhythms now the problem is that
lobsters the adult lobsters that you
guys all like to eat you're five to
seven years old
um and so they're not a great place to
do
development and you can't do
manipulations in development the same
way you could if you're working in a
flyer worm so we've done a fair bit of
work
and then we got it to a certain point
and then i just decided that
it was not the best preparation for
doing development
got it okay another question about
feedback into the network and that is
with regard to temperature
the question is do you believe that the
effect of temperature is purely passive
on the kinetics of the channels and
and and transmitter release or do you
think that there could also be
some modifying some sensing of
temperature
more centrally that then modifies the
behavior of the circuit
so in every animal that i know of there
are
neurons whose role is temperature
sensing
and that play a role often in
temperature preference
i think everything we've been studying
so far in the isolated
stomatogastric ganglion could be
accounted for
just on the on the behavior what you
call
passive temperature modulation but
i am sure in the animal there are
neurons whose function is temperature
sensing
as lobsters and crabs just like every
other animal i know
have mechanisms to to show temperature
preference and to follow temperature
gradients
i just don't think it's my sdg neurons
that are doing that for the animal
but enjoy they are somewhere that are
okay well thanks very much i think we
got to the general idea of most of the
questions and so i want to thank the
audience and
thanks eve for a very stimulating talk
and
and enjoy the rest of the evening the
session that's going on now
uh is on uh basically how do you
tell your story in science by liz nealy
the executive director of the
story collider so that's the next
presentation and again
thank you so much eve thanks everyone
for joining this
virtual brain investigative meeting
thank you bye guys
bye-bye